okay here we are back again
we've learnt about trees and how to use
trees in r and now we're going to see
how to use
trees um in
in the context of random forests and
boosting
and we'll see this gives us pretty
powerful
predictors
so
there's two packages random forest and
boost and gbm which does boost in we'll
start off with random forests
so
as we know random forests
will actually build lots of trees
and then average them and reduce the
variance of bushy trees
by averaging
so
we load the random forest package
and we're going to use the boston
housing data again and that's in the
mass package so we'll get that up we'll
set a random seed
and
let's have a look we see we got 506
observations in in in the boston housing
data
and
we're going to make a train instead of
size 300 so we'll use the same construct
as we used before
and we've got there we've got indexes
for training let's just look at the
boston housing data so we can we can
query we can run a help query on that
and we see it's the it's the
506
um suburbs of boston and for each suburb
we've got
demographics and things like crime per
capita
types of industry
average number of rooms per dwelling
average proportion
the age of the houses and various things
and what we're going to use as a
response
is the median value of owner-occupied
homes for each of these counties
for each of these suburbs okay
so it's a it's a dataset's been around
it was based on the 1970 census in in
boston
okay so
so we'll start off with a random forest
and it's
same kind of strong construct as before
response is medv
median value
and to be modeled as dot which means as
a function of all the other variables
and we want to use the train subset and
very fast random forests
and we can just print out the random
forest gives us a summary
and
it tells us the number of trees so that
was 500 trees were grown and they bushy
trees each of them so as you can see
that was pretty fast
and it gives you a summary of the fit it
gives you a means mean squared residual
and the percentage variance explained
and when we studied random forests in
the notes we talked about the out-of-bag
error so these are out-of-bag mean
squared residuals so each each
observation was predicted using the the
average of trees that didn't include it
so these are sort of uh
de-biased estimates of of
of prediction error
so
one of the tuning the pretty much only
tuning parameter in a random forest is
the variable called m tri the the
argument called m tri which is the
number of variables that are selected at
each split of each tree
when you when you come to make a split
so if m tri for example is four
of the 13 variables in the boston
housing data four selected at random
each time you come to split
a node
four would be selected at random and
then the split would be confined to to
one of those four variables
and so that's how random forest
decorrelates the trees so what we're
going to do is we're going to fit a
series of random forests
they're 13 variables so we're going to
have m try range through the values 1 to
13
and and then we're going to record the
errors and so we set up two variables to
do the recording of the errors and then
we go in a loop for m trine 1 to 13
we're going to fit the random forest
with that value of m tri and here we'll
just restrict the number of trees to be
400
for no good reason except that 400 is
sufficient here
and we give em try as an argument and of
course it's fit on the training data
and we can straight away plug in extract
the mean squared error because that's
out of bag error that's on the on the
object so we do that
and then we predict on the test data so
there's boston minus train and
passed as the data in the
argument to predict
and fit being the fit of the random
forest
and and then
we
compute the test error so there's our
width construction again
boston minus train and we compute the
mean
squared error so it's mean of mid v
minus spread squared mid v will be
picked off
the data frame boston minus train
so
these commands we've still in the loop
so it's not actually executed and then
we'll
we'll just
in case it takes long we'll we'll print
out the value of m try as it's going
okay so here we go and look how fast
that is
so it's 13 times 400 trees have been
grown here and it's done
and now we can make a plot and so we
actually use a matte plot command
because we've got two columns we've got
test.error
out of bag.era ub.error
so we see bind them together to make a
two-column matrix and then we make a
single plot with matplot
and you can see we put some other
arguments in the matrix we told it to
use
plotting character 19 which i i like
we gave two colors red and blue
and type equals b means type equals both
means it plots both points and connects
them with lines
and and we gave a y lab mean squared
error
and we can put a legend
in the top right corner
and we see the red points are out of bag
and the blue points are test error now
ideally those two curves should line up
pretty much
and it seems like the test error is a
bit lower
but be warned there's a lot of
variability in in these test error
estimates and so since the out of bag
was computed on one data set and the
test error on a different data set and
they weren't very large
these these differences are pretty much
well within the with the the standard
errors and don't get fooled by the fact
that that the red curve is smoothly
above the blue curve
these error estimates are very
correlated because the the random forest
with m tri equals four is very similar
to the one with m tri equals five and so
you know so that's what why these curves
each each of the curves is quite smooth
okay
um what we do see is that m try around
four
seems to be about the best at least for
the test error for the out-of-bag error
around about eight so somewhere in the
middle it's quite a flat plateau there
and
and and and with very little
with very few tears we've we've fit a
very powerful prediction model
um this is a random forest here and and
got pretty good performance just as a
point two points to note here on the
left hand side is a performance of a
single tree so this will be a bushy tree
but that's a performance of a single
bushy tree
and the mean squared error on the outer
bag is 26
and we drop down to about just over 14
years so it's almost it's just a little
bit above half so we
reduced the error by half and and
likewise for the test error in
these areas are somewhat different but
by using a random forest
and on the right hand side here we use
all 13 variables so this is actually
bagging which was random forest and
bagging were due to leo brymen bagging
came out earlier and random forests were
a later enhancement
and so
these are all produced using the random
forest function in r
now random forests as we learned in the
know in in the course notes
and lectures random forests reduce the
variance of the trees by averaging so it
grows big bushy trees and then gets rid
of the variants by averaging boosting on
the other hand
is really going off to bias
and so boosting grows
smaller stabia trees and then and and
goes at the bias
so we use the package gbm gradient
boosted machines
in r so we load up that package
and we're going to use the same data set
here and so
there we give a call to
gbm pretty much the same as the call to
random forest gbm asks for the
distribution which is gaussian because
we're doing squared error loss
we're going to ask gbm for 10 000 trees
which sounds like a lot
but these are going to be shallow trees
and that's given by interaction depth so
interaction depth is the number of
splits so we're going to say we only
want four splits in each of the trees
so it'll do best
first split in and and it'll stop it
after four splits and then shrinkage is
0.01 so that's how much we're going to
shrink the tree step back
so i just chose these parameters one
would normally fiddle around with these
parameters to decide which to use
and so here's jeep wow look at that 10
000 trees fit in in a few seconds
so we can do a summary
and what summary does is it it actually
gives a variable importance plot
and um
and it's
there's there's two variables that seem
to be the most important
there's the number of rooms
and
this this uh oh the second variable is
elstat which is the percentage of lower
status
economic status people in the in the
community
and so those are the two most important
variables
but they aren't all labeled in this plot
here because um because of the font size
we're using if we reduce the plant size
font size we would have seen them all
labeled so the variable importance plot
is a good way of seeing it seems like
these two variables are by far the most
important then the other variables play
a lesser role
we can do partial dependence plots so
let's plot these top two variables
and so this shows us it's kind of a
roughly relationship but that shows us
that uh
um
the the higher the proportion of lower
status
people in the in the suburb the lower
the value of of the house housing prices
not not a big surprise there
and
reverse relationship with the number of
rooms the average number of rooms in the
house
increases the price increases so no big
surprises there
okay so what we we're going to end off
the session by
by
by predicting our boosted model on the
test data set normally one would would
use cross validation in boosting to
select the number of trees we won't do
that yeah we'll leave that up to you to
do
you'd have to run the cross validation
yourself
and in fact these other tuning
parameters like the
shrinkage parameter is a
tuning parameter one would probably use
cross validation to select that as well
and so there's a little bit more work
and and fiddly stuff to be done with
boosting over random forest
but often it's worth it
so
what we'll do here is we'll just
look at the the test performance as a
function of the number of trees
and so we make a grid of number of trees
in steps of 100 from 100 to 10 000 by
okay so we use
seek to do that
and then we run the predict function on
on the boosted model
and it takes end or trees as an argument
and so
it was pretty quick and it's produced a
matrix of predictions on the test data
the 206 test observations
and you see we've got 100 different
predict vectors at those 100 different
values of of tree
and so then we compute the test error
for each of those
and we use the apply function so we use
our width command again and we use the
apply function
and now predmat's a matrix
but med v is a vector and so this just
recycles this vector so that's a little
bit of trickery that i i often use in r
it's handy
so
so that recycles it so this is actually
a matrix of differences and then we
apply to the columns
of these squared differences the mean
and so that'll compute the column wise
mean squared error
for these guys
um and it did that and then we'll
we'll make a plot and we see the the
boosting error plot
and it pretty much drops down
and drops down lower it looks like than
the random forest this is a function of
the number of trees and then it seems to
level off
and it doesn't appear to be increasing
if you if you really ramped up the
number of trees to a much bigger number
it would slowly start to increase but
this this is evidence of the of the
claim that boosting is reluctant to
overfit and it certainly seems to be the
case here
if we go back and replot our
random forest
performance
so
here we go
and and now we can go back in and
our
boosted results in that plot
we
see um it's doing about
no that's not what i wanted
okay i did the wrong plot
so there's our what i'm doing actually
what i'm intended to do was
there's our boosted plot and i'm going
to include the best test error from the
random forest over there so there we go
and we see that boosting actually got a
reasonable
amount below the test error for for the
random forest
okay so there we have it random forests
and boosting two powerful methods
um our experience is that boosting
especially if you're willing to go
through the tweaking and the tuning will
usually outperform random forests but
random forests are really dead easy
they won't overfit
the only tuning parameter is the m tri
but the number of
when i say they won't overfit
by by increasing the number of trees in
random forests it won't overfit it'll
it'll just
once it stabilizes it's stabilized and
adding more trees doesn't make much
difference with boosting not the case
you've got genuine tuning parameters a
number of trees
the the shrinkage parameter and and the
depth but both very powerful methods